[Musique]
nous sommes le lundi 22 octobre 2018
merci de nous rejoindre sur tv soixante
dix huit pour une nouvelle édition de
votre journal d'information locale voici
lé titre à 300 élèves de cm1 et de cm2
de neuf établissements scolaires des
longs cours se sont essayés au codage
informatique une opération dans le cadre
de la codp loïc et qui vient compléter
le dispositif école numérique de la
ville les mondiaux de cyclisme première
étape c'était au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines ce week end le
bilan des tricolores des yvelinois lors
de notre page sports et puis être des
bénévoles au chevet du patrimoine de la
vallée de chevreuse comme chaque lundi
nous nous rendrons dans le parc naturel
afin de faire ce soir un focus sur une
opération et qui a permis de restaurer
et à nettoyer le patrimoine c'était
pendant l'été dernier on débute par de
la politique
invité ce matin de lci la députée la
république en marche des yvelines
également porte parole du groupe à
l'assemblée aurore bergé s'est elle
s'est exprimée notamment sur jean luc
mélenchon et la france 1 soumises elles
ce sont je cite des gens dangereux dans
leurs méthodes et dans leurs discours
jean luc mélenchon est en train de
montrer le vrai visage de l'extrême
gauche
fin de citation concernant le projet de
gpa elle se dit fermement opposé écoutez
là je suis totalement opposé à la gt r
parce que je vois bien qu'en ce moment
certains tendent à démontrer que
finalement les jets pèse quelque chose
de facile que tout se passe bien
peut-être qu'à des cas où ça se passe
extraordinairement parle évidemment la
médiatisation par exemple inondations
très forte autour d'un livre et je ne
conteste absolument pas le fait qu'il
doit être un père formidable
ils font une famille forme même c'est
pas le sujet le sujet c'est que quoi
qu'il arrive une gpa ça veut dire que
vous avez recours à une mère porteuse
vous avez une marchandisation du corps
de la femme et ça c'est quelque chose
que je peux pas accepter éducation à
présent il sera bientôt aussi important
de savoir coder que de savoir écrire ou
parler partant de ce constat à la codp
week entend sensibiliser elle les
enfants au sein de leur établissement à
l'école de la vie
dieu d'elancourt des élèves de cm1 et de
cm2 viennent d'apprendre à créer une
application manon varaldo à elancourt
les tablettes ont remplacé les cours
d'histoire d'anglais et de poésie lors
de la causerie qu à l'école de
lavilledieu une animation pédagogique
dédié à l'apprentissage du code est
proposé ce qui nous a semblé intéressant
c'est que là les enfants aujourd'hui mon
à prendre selon une application qui
s'appelle swift play ground a programmé
une application mobile sur leurs
tablettes
300 enfants de cm1 et cm2 apprennent à
créer une application mobile en
s'amusant
le but former les élèves dès le plus
jeune âge et les préparer aux métiers de
demain
l'aco douik s'inscrit dans le dispositif
d'école numérique d'elancourt une
satisfaction tant pour les élèves que
les professeurs je trouve que pour une
première approche sahamies en émulation
toute la classe ils ont été très heureux
vous pouvez le voir de découvrir
l'application find et je pense que pour
une première approche c'est vraiment
très intéressant mais on ne va pas
s'arrêter là à mon avis le conseil
départemental et l'éducation nationale
réfléchisse à un projet proposé à
l'ensemble des douze villes de
l'agglomération de démarrer en janvier
un programme d'équipement et de
formation dans les écoles élémentaires
avec toujours le même but
l'apprentissage du numérique et ce soir
pour le point sportif du à lundi jacques
et grégory canal et bonsoir oui j'ai
volé votre place ce soir vous avez pris
celle de michael et demi d'euros et on
va faire le point avec vous sur les
championnats du monde de cyclisme
première étape qui avait lieu ce week
end à saint quentin en yvelines et il
faut retenir wilfried un bilan mitigé
pour les pistards français trois petites
médailles obtenues à l'argent en vitesse
par équipes pour le trio baugé vigier
d'almeida médaille de bronze en scratch
pour adrien garrel barge en atom à lui
remporté le bronze dans la catégorie
omnium est la délégation française
entendait pourtant scorer sur cette
première manche avec notamment 1
mathilde grolleau jeunes pousses
tricolores elle malgré le soutien de sa
famille c'est une quatrième place au
sprint et seulement 8e place au keirin
catégorie pour laquelle elle avait
obtenu un titre de championne d'europe
il ya forcément de la déception dans la
voix du directeur technique national
mathilde gros elle veut retenir le
positif écouter quelques quelques
regrets on était à domicile on espérait
peut-être avoir des résultats des
meilleurs résultats on a tenté
du genre de nos sportifs sont sortis
assez rapidement
dans les manches de qualification donc
quelques regrets plutôt prendre les
points positifs regarder toutes les
erreurs tactiques que j'ai fait pour
pouvoir aller mettre en oeuvre enfin
voilà justement de ne pas faire les
mêmes erreurs dans une semaine à toronto
donc pour l'instant je ferai un bilan de
semaine afin les deux bouts d'une petite
déception tout de même pour mathilde et
qui va devoir rebondir par la suite côté
organisation est ce que cette première
manche est un succès eh bien c'était la
première fois que l'enceinte
saint-quentinoise recevait l'événement
environ 3000 spectateurs sont venus
chaque jour sur ce vélodrome qui compte
pour à peine 5000 places qui n'a donc
pas été complètement rempli mais ça
reste satisfaisant à 25 nations étaient
représentées c'était donc une bonne
répétition en vue de ces jeux olympiques
2020 très 4 qui arrive pour le vélodrome
saint quentinois qui accueillera pour
rappel des épreuves le vélodrome a plu
aux athlètes présents écoutent à ce
propos cette pistarde italienne est
aussi la ministre des sports en
déplacement samedi au vélodrome
une belle répétition d'organiser des
coupes du monde et championnats du monde
chez nous en france dans cette
installation
la fédération il faire aussi ses armes
en tant qu'organisateurs et bien sûr les
territoires qui sont aussi présentes
les élus qui pour voir aussi de quoi il
s'agit parce que ce qu'on prendre des
décisions en connaissance de cause c'est
toujours mieux et je ne l'imaginé pas
comme ça s'il est vraiment très beau je
souhaite bonne chance au vélodrome pour
les jeux olympiques qui l'accueillera
c'est vrai que le che tourisme y ait
accès au nouveau en europe et balotelli
est le vélodrome de 50 en une qui
devrait de nouveau accueillir une
épreuve de la coupe du monde du de
cyclisme sur piste une manche de cette
coupe du monde et ce dès la saison
prochaine
merci grégory on vous retrouve à 18h30
si vous nous suivez en direct pour le
7-8 sport le point complet sur ces
mondiaux de cyclisme et puis sur
l'actualité yvelinoise saint-quentinoise
en matière de sport merci
et puis sachez qu'à l'occasion de cet
événement saint quentin en yvelines a
été être distingué par l'union cycliste
internationale pour son implication dans
la promotion du vélo et dans
l'organisation de grandes compétitions
internationales de cyclisme le label us
et ea a été remis vendredi en ouverture
des mondiaux huit villes ou régions dans
le monde ont déjà été récompensés mais
c'est une première en france
les efforts en matière de mobilité pour
le plus grand nombre ont aussi été
apprécié
quand on parle de vélo il ne s'agit pas
que de sport il s'agit aussi de
déplacement sa mode de déplacement doux
non polluants le vélo est très ancien
mais c'est aussi l'avenir tout
simplement d'un roman 9 beaucoup de
choses
c'est par exemple des stations relais
vélo hangar qui permettent aux saint
quentinois ou aux salariés saint
quentinois d'aller ou de venir à leur
travail en vélo de gares et de manière
sécurisée alors vers leurs vélos à la
gare
ce sont des nouvelles pistes cycle des
cyclables existantes ou à construire
donc beaucoup d'actions pour permettre à
chacun de pratiquer le vélo du sport à
la culture avec la finale régionale de
breakdance bboy france c'était ce week
end à la merise attrape ultime étape
avant la finale nationale de liévin
c'est dans le pas de calais marylène
yapi chinois
des pionniers de la glande heures dans
les années 80 à la finale régionale bboy
france la danse hip hop a fait du chemin
et a toujours sa place à traves
l'association wav cet événement ne mord
pas en charge du championnat s'est
associé à la nourrice pour accueillir
l'événement il ya trois catégories qui
vont se disputer la 7e cette fin d'après
midi
voilà il faut savoir qu'il ya toute la
sélection rend toute l'après midi on
avait une soixantaine de danseurs qui se
sont affrontés pour finalement non voilà
on en retenir
on va dire que un seul par catégorie
ah ah
dans la catégorie pop rock où les
danseurs foule debout deux trappistes
ont défendu des couleurs de
l'association street hip hop
tous deux se sont qualifiés pour la
finale régionale foulani va affronter
son grand le terme utilisé dans le
milieu pour désigner son professeur
savoir que chez attrape à la maison dans
mon quartier avec mon grand qui m'a tout
à fait c'est une grande émotion pour moi
j'ai très fier d'elle j'espère que va
postuler est toujours aussi discipliné
dans son travail assidu et dans la
finesse
regard et surtout l'accomplissement de
soi la petite a finalement surpassé son
grand c'est elle qui représentera l'île
de france de la catégorie top rock le 10
novembre à liévin dans le pas de calais
[Musique]
chaque lundi depuis cette rentrée nous
partons pour le parc naturel de la haute
vallée de chevreuse pourrez découvrir
les richesses les initiatives menées
aujourd'hui retour sur un projet mené à
son chant pendant l'été et qui a permis
à des bénévoles des étrangers de
restaurer les glacières du château de
pinceau jules colis que ce soit pour des
insertions professionnelles ou des
chantiers bénévoles l'association études
et chantiers propose depuis 2001 des
projets collectifs d'intérêt général
dans 80 pays
comme c'est le cas sur ce chantier de
rénovation des glacières du château de
pain seul ou à son chant et plusieurs
branches fia et les espaces verts la
maçonnerie
il faut également un atelier vélo bon
voilà dans un but écologique qu'on est
là pour justement réhabiliter un petit
peu le terrain donc pour faire du
nettoyage pour redonner vie un peu à ces
monuments historiques et des actions
soutenues par le pnr de la vallée de
chevreuse ce chantier bénévole mélange
des jeunes adultes du monde entier
autour d'un véritable travail d'équipé
on a les japonais on l'avait mexicain on
a des espagnols les allemands des turcs
des pakistanais et
je n'ai peut-être rien oui donc je suis
désolé mais beaucoup c'est vraiment
cosmopolite c'est vraiment une mixité
richesse culturelle aussi donc c'est
vraiment génial et c'est donc par ce
mélange d'origines dans un travail
collectif que se crée des liens
puissants entre les différents
participants tout en leur faisant
découvrir de nombreuses cultures
c'est vraiment des jeunes qui ce qui
participe énormément ils sont
volontaires ils travaillent vraiment
bien j'ai rien à dire c'est une superbe
équipe pour des gens qui ne sont pas du
tout du métier en plus donc c'est assez
vraiment agréable à vivre
ouvert à tous de 14 à 99 ans sans
condition de diplôme de compétence ou de
niveau de langue
ces chantiers sont de véritables
expériences de vie mêlant insertion
professionnelle et rencontres
le tout dans une ambiance très
conviviale enfin ce fin de cette édition
pardon le journal revient mardi 18h en
direct replay sur notre site internet
notre application mobile vos
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux
vous en avez l'habitude excellente
soirée et bonnes vacances à ceux qui
peuvent en profiter
[Musique]